en cette période de fêtes à l'heure du
goûter le château d'azay-le-rideau
accorde une grande place à la
gourmandise
les visiteurs sont plongés dans un
univers du sucre et des épices et du
chocolat au départ et pendant très
longtemps la selle chocolat qu'on essaie
cet élément boissons du chocolat il faut
attendre seulement les dix neuvième
siècle dont vous voyez il ya pas très
longtemps pour obtenir d'abord les
barres de chocolat sur le thème douceur
et chocolat pour cette période de fêtes
le château renouer avec son passé
agricole et gourmand quand on parle du
château d'azay-le-rideau très souvent on
oublie qu'au départ c'est un domaine
agricole
je veux faire référence au 19e siècle à
l'époque le château d'azay-le-rideau
c'est un domaine de 950 ha et on connaît
parfaitement la vie du domaine le nom de
la cuisinière des marques billancourt
on connaît le nom du régisseur du
jardinier en chef
on sait que les légumes qui sont
produits dans le potager débit en cours
sont utilisés par la cuisinière pour
faire des marmelades pour faire des
confitures des bocaux et cetera au fil
des salles d'exposition et des
dégustations
oprean bout à l'histoire nous avons mis
en place
des visites gourmandes or que nos
visiteurs d'ailleurs adore non seulement
parce qu'il se régale mais ça permet de
découvrir cette histoire dont je parlais
qui est une histoire qui ne se voit pas
dans les pierres ou dans l'architecturé
du château puisque c'est la vie
quotidienne du château avec donc des
personnes qui cuisinent dans d'ailleurs
dans cette cuisine faut bien imaginer
qu'il y avait des odeurs de rôti des
odeurs des odeurs de gâteau au chocolat
ou et donc
ces visites gourmandes sait ce qu elle
sait ce qu'elle raconte
c'est ce qu'elle raconte à l'intérieur
du château avec friandises et chocolat
sans modération la visite séduit
incontestablement le jeune public que
j'ai surtout aimé pour me regarder la
confiture parce que j'adore et j'ai
adoré là qu'on peut regarder la cuisine
je mangeais macarons la pâte de fruit et
chocolat est pas tout était déjà
beaucoup aimé le macaron et
j'ai bien aimé le fait de visiter le
château en manche en satin chocolat